pour voir lyon par exemple au spa ou
encore à courir alors qu'avec les
changements climatiques
ici plus fou plus abstrait j'en ai pas
beaucoup réagi à la menace là on a vu
dans les dernières semaines des
milliards de personnes sur la planète se
mobiliser face à la cofidis
on peut maintenant se poser la question
est ce que ce genre de mobilisation pour
être un exemple pour la lutte aux
changements climatiques que certaines
similitudes dans une situation meilleure
grande différence
la distance psychologique ou autrement
dit la perception de l'imminence du
danger
au départ il y avait une certaine
distance psychologique lié à ce virus là
c'était compliqué en chine pour la poule
la rade parce que logique est terrifié
ça devenait de plus en plus comptés vous
voyez les images envoyées que celles
auxquelles sera augmentée rapidement
l'école active le système appétit en
fait on répond davantage à la menace
passe comme ça dans l'autre il justement
des changements climatiques souvent on
pense que son lointain audience ça va se
passer dans d'autres pays plus loin puis
lointain au niveau du temps on ne les
reverra répondre aux risques à la menace
et allume pauvre maman les parties
notamment qui devrait le plus saillant
un coup on goûte à la solidarité et à
l'engagement collectif à l'action
collective comme ça mais on aime ça
parce que ça crée du centre dans
l'adversité qui ont envie de l'anxiété
et qu'on agit pour juste âgée pour nous
protéger nous mais qu'on agit pour le
bien commun mais c'est vraiment porteur
de sens est ce que justement à mort
connu cette altérité leur ok mais quel
autre cause que je pourrais aussi
continuer à appliquer parce que j'aime
ce sentiment communautaire le savez déjà
pourrait se retourner une vari
changement climatique surtout que ben
c'est assez lié à énormément parallèle
apparent changement climatique la crise
ont mis en ce moment
quand on parle de transition normalement
s'est pas posé avec un choc sous deux
semaines
il pose sur la transition mais le but
justement si vite et c'est crise il
aussi comment on peut se préparer un
climat marqué ce que tu en fais des
moqueries
car quel point on est vulnérable puis à
quel point on y insère des pantins
j'espère que là qu'il aux mamans vont me
faire réfléchir à kimi le haut
cette vulnérabilité le comac ont la
décence
[Musique]
les actions de solidarité juste part et
concluent les attentions en ce moment à
bord du bateau au québec
sarassoro mais l'on se faire connecter
ou vous connecter à quelque chose de
plus grand mouvement n'aurait fait de
sentiments face ans dans son cou puis ok
on n'est pas seuls on fait partie d'un
groupe de quelque chose lui quelque
chose enfants mais comment on fait
maintenant pour s'organiser
très belle opportunité pour repenser
notre façon d'être au monde